butterfinger is such a versatile
ingredient because you can add it into
any of your favorite baked goods or use
it as a topping hey everyone it's hannah
and today i'm making these delicious
mini butterfinger cheesecakes this
recipe comes from brianna s the winner
of our butterfinger baking contest
the best kind of cheesecake crust is a
cookie crust so i always do that for
cheesecakes and i was so excited to see
that for this recipe it's really simple
you just crush up cookies add melted
butter and press it into a mold and it's
the perfect crust
the filling is really simple it's just
cream cheese sugar eggs and vanilla beat
that all together until it's smooth you
might know it as a delicious chocolate
bar but butterfinger is now for bakers
too
you have to add these butterfinger bits
on top of your cookie crust it's going
to make your cheesecake taste incredible
if you can't find butter finger bits
just chop up or crush butterfinger bars
it works perfectly now because these are
mini cheesecakes i like to put the
filling in a piping bag because it's
just really precise to pour it into the
cups
my kids love butter fingers so when they
saw the bits they were so excited to try
these in a recipe and we've been using
them ever since
grab yourself a butterfinger and show us
your creation with hashtag bake better
with butterfinger
these are so good